SUBJECT: Vladimir Putin, besides
being the leader of the largest
country in the world,
is a manly man,
or at least that's
the vibe he gives off
by doing things like fishing
with no shirt, practicing Judo
with worthy opponents, or
by befriending the Night
Wolves, Russia's
biggest motorcycle gang.
The night walls are led by this
guy, Alexander Zaldostanov,
also known as The Surgeon.
Now that seems kind
of intimidating
especially in the context
of a hulking tattooed leader
of a motorcycle gang.
But apparently, Zaldostanov
was actually a surgeon,
a literal licensed surgeon.
These images of the
Night Wolves were
taken by Russian
photographer, Sergey Nikolaev
during the grand opening
of biker season, which
I assume is when the weather
gets warm enough for motorcycle
rides and not when hunters
can legal negotiating out
and capture and tame
wild motorcycle.
Annual opening of the motorcycle
season in Saint Petersburg
begins in the heart of the
city at the Palace Square.
Members of all motorcycle
clubs get together
where they go to a place
celebration as a united
great column.
On this day, Zaldostanov
and the Night Wolves
were at the head of the column.
He has come at the opening
of seasons in Saint
Petersburg for the first time.
I felt compelled to
capture the event,
because Zaldostanov
is a celebrity,
a major person and his
participation in the opening
was not typical for our city.
And that seems to be
how a lot of Russians
perceived The Surgeon and
his gang, as celebrities.
And they like what
they stand for.
In my opinion, the
majority of Russians
suffered the ideas promoted
by the Night Wolves.
Those Night Wolf endorsed
ideas are immense patriotism,
a strong belief in the
Russian Orthodox Church,
and also sentiments that are
anti-west, anti-feminism,
anti-gay, and
anti-Ukrainian revolution.
And because they're so
outspoken about these beliefs,
others inside Russia don't see
them the celebrities at all.
Other Russian motorcycle
gangs, in particular,
aren't big fans of
the Night Wolves.
Motorcycle gangs are famous
for having fierce rivalries.
But this time, it's not because
of drugs, or territory rights,
or someone's old lady.
Russian gangs, like the
Dobermans and Russia's chapters
of Hell's Angels,
think that there's
no place for
politics and religion
in the world of
motorcycle gangs.
The Night Wolves
think otherwise.
Not only do they make bike
pilgrimages to holy sites,
but they're basically a Putin
PR department on two wheels.
As a publicly
recognized close friend
of the gang, Putin
his gifted them
state land along
with government money
to help build a
new headquarters.
And he sold land to
the gang in Crimea
for 0.1% of its actual
price so that they
could build a patriotic center
for entertainment and extreme
sports.
One biker one as far as saying
that the Russian motorcycle
community is divided in two,
on the one side of the Night
Wolves, on the other
side, everybody else.
Outside of Russia,
the night wolves
have been sanctioned
because of their close ties
to the Kremlin.
The United States has barred the
gang from entering the country
or doing any financial
dealings with the US,
because sub-members took
up arms in Russia's fight
against Ukraine.
During the conflict they
stormed a natural gas facility
in Sebastopol,
which by the way, is
the same town their new
sports center will be located.
They have also been banned
from entering Canada, Germany,
Poland, and the
entire European Union.
But the Night Wolves consider
this an accomplishment
as international recognition
for their support
of their beloved home country,
a country where people will line
up just to watch them
ride down the street,
a country where a
motorcycle gang can
be a national treasure,
and its leader, the best
friend of the President.
The Cold War might
be over, but there
are few places left in Russia
that really don't act that way.
Click now to check
out our new video
on Russia's secret cities.
Throughout the Cold
War the Soviet Union
created 44 cities that were
kept secret from the world.
These cities were dedicated to
making weaponry, specifically
nuclear bombs.
If you haven't already, please
subscribe to this channel.
And as always
Thanks for watching.